Tracy I have to ask you you love to make
people laugh I have had personal
experience trying to make cube laugh
several times and it is it is not easy
duel comedy for him was like performing
in front of Darth Vader yeah would you
try a lot would you try a lot of stuff
constantly yeah that did something for
my self-esteem yeah if I can to descend
on me if I got ice cube to lap that's
that's that's a notch in my belt yeah I
could tell if the gods around my way I'm
a ice cube laughs me don't you talk
about funny I make you black yeah have
you always been that way it's you're
tough right you're a tough laugh I mean
you got to be funny
well Larry actually want to try now
thank you
hey no it didn't work the old how's it
going
[Laughter]
you